History,
emotional anxiety,
anxiety about emotions and thinkers from
the classical period to the modern have
pitted emotion against reason as
opposing forces vying for the minds,
control and emotional person was seen as
weak,
giving into the path of least resistance
to base desires ruled by capricious
feelings.
Q is the path to the dark side.
Strong on the other hand,
would rule their emotions with reason.
Everyone feels pressure.
Winners don't let it show.
Disney personified this struggle in a
short eight minute cartoon from 1943
called aptly reason and emotion within
each of us.
These two wages ceaseless back from
mastering the short is a lightly
disguised propaganda piece,
heartening Americans against fear
tactics used by the axis powers in World
War II,
but it was nonetheless a point of
reference for the Pixar team,
led by director Pete doctor responsible
for the film inside out.
Doctors.
Film is a far more nuanced take on the
inner workings of the mind,
appropriate for a post 40 and post
cultural revolution age when we're
encouraged extensively at least to
embrace emotions rather than urged to
masterman.
The film tells the story of the 11 year
old Riley as she navigates a move across
the country and more centrally,
how five emotions,
joy,
the leader sadness,
fear,
disgust,
and anger balanced the control of her
mind from a mission control like
headquarters in this model,
each day consists of discrete moments
colored by one of the five emotions
which are sent during sleep to a vast
archive of longterm memories,
very rarely inexperienced is so
formative that it creates a core memory
which goes on to form the basis of
Riley's personality,
imagined as themed Park Islands when joy
and sadness are accidentally injected
from headquarters.
The film chronicles their Cathartic
journey through several other mental
regions,
including imagination land,
a dream production company that looks
like the paramount lot abstract thought
and a subconscious jail.
The Catharsis comes when joy realizes
that sadness is not only useful but
essential,
perhaps even more essential than she is
to Riley's harmonious,
mental functioning and overall
happiness.
The film itself and its message to
embrace sadness,
to feel what needs feeling is surely a
token of progress against our long
standing emotional anxiety,
but is this model of the mind and its
emotions and accurate one inside out
basis.
It's theory of emotions in large part on
the work of Paul Ekman and influential
scientists in the psychology of emotion,
Ekman posits that there are seven basic
emotions with universal facial signals.
The ones featured in the film plus two
that were cut,
surprise and content.
These basic emotions are ubiquitous.
The world over Eckman says,
and can be read on the faces of anyone,
whether that's by an astute listener or
facial recognition.
Software like those Ekman has helped
develop controversially for security and
marketing uses.
Ekman and other consultants on the film
have praised inside out for providing a
model for kids that is engaging as well
as scientifically sound,
but the edmunds model may be the
dominant one in the psychology of
emotion.
Right now,
it's by no means the only indeed the
field is a far more fractious one than
the film scientific consultants lead on
inside out seems to suggest that a
child's experiences will be defined by
whichever emotion is at the health.
What's more that overall personality
determined by colored core memories has
an emotional driver.
This model stands opposite to the key
insights of psychoanalysis,
for example,
which hold that emotions can be
transferred,
transformed or distorted expressions of
unconscious ideas and repressed
experiences.
In other words,
feelings of sadness or joy or fear are
frequently far removed from their
causes.
Understanding them as specific entities
is troublesome because they're often not
what they seem to be,
which is to say that understanding of
motion as the driver and not the
expression of ideas and experience may
ignore underlying causes.
Indeed,
the idea that emotions or memories can
be separate or discrete in any way is a
dubious one.
The film itself begins to challenge this
at the end when the control panel in
headquarters is expanded to fit all the
emotions and when the memory orb start
to reflect mixed experience,
but a sense that experience can be
quantified,
pervades the film and like anything that
may reflect more about our culture at
the moment than the science itself for
joy and sadness.
The scariest place in the film isn't the
subconscious prison that houses Riley's
worst fears,
but a giant pit in the center of Riley's
mine where memories are forgotten
forever without any hope of recall in an
increasingly data driven culture where
more data equals more truth.
The greatest anxiety of all is the loss
of information and the headquarters of
Riley's.
Mine does feel a bit managerial with its
control panel and user manuals and
Riley,
a bit like an automaton controlled by a
highly sophisticated technocratic
operation.
The decision making process is a bit
wonky to since the latest neuroscience
tells us that the frontal lobe and Max
kind of executive function that mediates
between the emotions and the limbic
system and higher cognitive functions
like reflection and critical thinking.
Obviously not always in favor of the.
Maybe
at this point you're saying the same
thing as the voice.
In my own head,
it's a kid's movie.
It's a comedy and that's very true,
and the director,
Pete doctor,
has never held this film up
as an academic or therapeutic tool.
He admits the need for poetic and
comedic license to adding an executive
function like the kind of just
mentioned,
for example,
would no doubt make the film too
complex,
as with any number of other things like
the two basic emotions he left out or
any other emotion,
I don't think his dramatic instincts can
be questioned here under the premises of
the emotional model that inside out
presents the narrative unfolds with
grace,
subtle,
deep and intense poignancy.
I'll leave the formal critique to
someone else,
but there's no doubt that this is
masterful filmmaking.
I had the tiers to prove it,
but it does raise questions about the
effect of popular models of the mind.
Pixar tell stories so mythic and
archetipal and so well that it's all but
impossible not to internalize some of
their elements,
especially for kids.
If the result is that children learn
earlier and better why it's important to
accept and expect sadness,
then I think it's unquestionably a good
thing,
but sadness and joy and fear and disgust
and anger are not discrete things or
self contained or even fully internal.
Neither are personality traits or for
that matter personalities,
any model of emotion is going to reflect
a split between biology and culture,
between neuroscience and theoretical
psychoanalysis.
Don't let anyone tell you that that
debate has been decided one way or the
other.
There are as many emotional theories as
there are emotional psychologists.
What's interesting and ironic about
inside out is that Riley may come off as
a bit robotic,
but a more complex and complete
framework for the inner workings of the
mind can be found.
Enjoy herself.
A character who questions and reflects
who turns inward not to another smaller
headquarters,
but a cauldron of indistinct compounds
of feeling influenced by chemistry
situation and other people inside out
may not be perfectly accurate,
but the film inspires something more
important than that.
Something that doesn't require
scientific exactness,
emotional intelligence.
It is a sunny day outside right now.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
I'm,
I love Pixar generally,
but I love this movie just because it
gives you so much to dig into an
explorer and I had a lot of fun making
this and putting this together.
Um,
if you think that the nerd writer and
what I'm doing here is something that
you're not seeing elsewhere on youtube,
you can pledge little to my channel by
clicking here and going to my patriots
what funds this project and helps me
improve the quality.
There's so much more I want to do.
There's more series that I'm going to be
introducing soon.
And the funding is what makes it
possible.
I mean that.
That's the unique relationship between
you and me.
There's nothing in between us and what
you give me.
The money you give me helps me to make
this project better and more in depth.
And I hope that you trust that I will do
that by,
by the quality of the content that I've
made so far.
So thank you so much again for watching
and I'll see you guys next Wednesday.